organizations, it most definitely will
not work in a post-quantum, post-AI
context around how we do security. The
web is grossly insecure. It has
absolutely no way that it should be
being used for sensitive data, for
economic data, for economic value. And
yet it is. The illusion has got to be
gone now with with Mythos uh and Project
Glasswing.
The whole idea of how we approach
security is totally different because we
built this to be something that the
real-world commercial
universe can operate with. That these
are the things that when we work with
real money and real sensitive data, that
we actually need to have these levels of
security. And it's not even about
creating levels. Forgive me, that's
misleading.
It's not about that defense-in-depth as
an answer. It isn't an answer.
The answer, correctly, is to separate
the concerns and address the fact that
well, that if you don't have an attack
surface, what do you attack? How do you
How do you grab this information? And
with grids you cannot.
The signing context is physically
separated from the execution context.
This is huge. This level